la vida glamorosa.
Y desde mi óptica,
allá cerca de una base militar en Lawon, Oklahoma,
no había diferencia entre un presentador de noticias y un actor.
Para mí era lo mismo.
Las opciones eran:
"Informando en vivo desde Berlín"
o bien,
"Aquí la espero. En cuanto llegue le voy a hacer la corte como se debe".
(Risas)
Todo se veía tan especial.
Era ser el centro de atención,
y yo estaba convencido de que aquello era para mí.
Pero en algún punto del camino,
mi vida dio un giro.
Ah, mejor así.
(Aplausos)
Tengo una enfermedad que se llama vitiligo.
Apareció a principios de mi carrera.
Es un trastorno autoinmune.
Se manifiesta con la aparición de manchas blancas en la piel
pero, en realidad, es la piel que pierde su color.
Afecta a todas las etnias,
a todas las edades,
a todos los géneros.
No es contagioso,
no es potencialmente mortal,
pero es una batalla mental.
Es duro.
Ahora bien, la enfermedad apareció
cuando trabajaba en "Eyewitness News" en la ciudad de Nueva York.
Estaba en la ciudad más grande del país,
en la estación central de emisión,
y trabajaba en el noticiero más visto de las 5 de la tarde.
Y el médico me miró directo a los ojos y me dijo:
"Tiene una enfermedad llamada vitiligo
que consiste en la pérdida de pigmentación de la piel.
No tiene cura, pero existen bla, bla, bla, bla...
La maestra de Charlie Brown.
(Risas)
Me dijo que no tenía cura,
pero lo que yo interpreté fue: "Mi carrera está terminada".
Pero no me podía dar por vencido.
No podía renunciar,
porque el esfuerzo que pusimos fue inmenso.
Y al decir "pusimos" me refiero al Sr. Moss,
que me envió a clases de teatro y oratoria, en lugar de castigarme,
o a mi hermana, que pagó parte de mis gastos universitarios,
o mi madre,
que, simplemente, me dio todo.
No iba a darme por vencido.
Decidí entonces usar maquillaje y seguir adelante.
De todas maneras, tenía que usarlo. Estaba en la tele, ¿o no?
Simplemente usaba más maquillaje, y todo iba sobre ruedas.
Y funcionó muy bien, durante años.
Pasé de ser periodista en Nueva York
a ser presentador del programa matutino en Detroit,
la ciudad de los automóviles.
Y a medida que la enfermedad avanzaba
simplemente usaba más maquillaje.
Era fácil.
Excepto las manos.
Esta enfermedad es progresiva y va cambiando constantemente.
Es decir, va y viene.
Hubo un momento en que, durante un año y medio,
la cara se me quedó completamente blanca.
Sí, a mí también me impresiona.
(Risas)
Sí.
Y luego, con un poco de ayuda,
parte del pigmento se regeneró.
Pero atravesar ese proceso
fue como dos caras de la misma moneda.
Cuando estoy con el maquillaje, ya bien en el trabajo o en la calle,
soy el de la tele.
Todos me saludan. Genial.
Pero en casa, sin el maquillaje,
cuando me lo que quitaba, era como ser un leproso.
Las miradas, esas miradas permanentes,
los comentarios por lo bajo.
Algunos no querían estrecharme la mano.
Otros se cruzaban de acera,
se alejaban en el ascensor.
Para mí, era como si se cruzaran al otro lado de la vida.
Era muy duro,
y fueron años muy difíciles.
Y, a decir verdad,
a veces tenía que refugiarme en mí mismo.
Me refiero a que tenía que quedarme en casa
para acomodar mis pensamientos.
Pero luego, me volvía a poner las anteojeras,
salía al mundo de nuevo,
hacía mis actividades,
pero en ese proceso, fui construyendo
un personalidad malhumorada, con actitudes de enojo.
La ira es un lugar común,
y la gente me dejaba solo,
pero es que ese no era yo.
No era yo.
Estaba dando lugar a que la enfermedad me transforme
en un gruñón malhumorado, lleno de manchas.
Ese no era yo.
Y tuve que cambiar.
Sabía que no podía cambiar a los demás.
Los demás reaccionarían y actuarían como les viniera en gana.
Pero había también una realidad dura, fría.
Ero tan solo yo
quien mostraba su ira, su tristeza,
quien se aislaba del resto.
Era algo que yo mismo había elegido.
Salía al mundo todos los días
esperando a que los demás reaccionaran de manera negativa,
pero yo me adelantaba y les mostraba mi lado negativo, antes que ellos.
Si quería un cambio, el cambio debía empezar por mí mismo.
Se me ocurrió entonces un plan.
Un plan de dos partes, nada complicado.
Número uno: dejaría que la gente me observara,
cuanto quisiera, el tiempo que fuera,
y yo no reaccionaría.
Porque, en realidad, cuando contraje esta enfermedad,
me la pasaba frente al espejo observando cada nueva mancha
y tratando de entender qué me pasaba.
Y necesitaba permitir que los demás tuvieran la misma oportunidad
de comprenderlo visualmente.
Número dos:
reaccionaría de manera positiva
y eso implicaba una simple sonrisa
o, al menos,
una expresión amable, libre de todo prejuicio.
Un plan muy simple.
Pero terminó siendo más difícil de lo que pensaba.
Pero con el tiempo,
las cosas empezaron a funcionar.
Como la vez que fui a una tienda y un tipo empezó a mirarme,
con una mirada que me atravesaba de lado a lado
mientras hacía las compras.
Fui a la caja a pagar y seguía mirándome.
Mientras pagaba, me seguía mirando desde la fila de al lado.
Nos encontramos en la salida y seguía mirándome.
No dejaba de mirarme,
finalmente me acerco y le digo: "¡Oye, amigo, qué pasa!".
Y me contesta...
(Balbucea con nerviosismo) "¡Hola!".
(Risas)
Incómodo, por cierto.
Y para distender un poco, le digo:
"Es tan solo un trastorno de la piel.
No es contagioso, no es mortal, tan solo me hace un poco diferente".
Al final, hablamos como cinco minutos.
Genial, ¿o no?
Y sobre el final de la conversación, me dice:
"Sabes, si no tuvieras viti... eso" ...
Lo correcto es "vitiligo", pero, en fin, su intención era buena...
(Risas)
"Si no tuvieras viti... eso, te parecerías al tipo del la tele".
Le dije: "Ja ja, sí, puede ser, claro".
(Risas)
Hasta allí, todo iba saliendo bien.
Iba acumulando más experiencias positivas que negativas,
hasta aquel día.
Antes del trabajo, me tomaba un tiempo
y me iba al parque a ver jugar a los niños.
Son divertidos.
Sin querer, me puse muy cerca de una niña que estaba distraída,
una niña de dos o tres años,
que se echa a correr hacia mí, se topa con mis piernas y cae.
Pensé que se había lastimado
Me acerco para levantarla,
y cuando ve mi vitiligo
¡empieza a gritar desesperada!
Bien sabemos que los niños son sinceros.
Tenía dos o tres años.
Estaba claro que su intención no era incomodarme.
No tenía maldad alguna.
Lo que le pasó fue que se asustó.
Simplemente, sintió miedo.
Yo no sabía qué hacer.
Tan solo retrocedí y puse las manos a un costado.
Me recluí en mi casa dos semanas y tres días luego de aquella anécdota.
Me llevó un segundo procesar la idea de que podía asustar a los niños.
Y eso ya no lo podía enfrentar con una sonrisa.
Pero insistí con mi plan,
me puse las anteojeras
y volví a salir al mundo.
A los dos meses, en un supermercado, me agacho para sacar un producto
y oigo una vocecita que dice: "¿Te has hecho pupa?".
Una niña de dos o tres años, de nuevo, de la misma edad,
pero no grita.
Entonces me arrodillo frente a ella
y como no conozco esa media lengua, miro a la madre
y le digo: "¿Qué me ha dicho?".
Me contesta: "Cree que te has hecho pupa".
Entonces le digo:
"No, no me ha pasado nada, de verdad".
Y la niña dice: "¿Dole?".
Le pido a la madre que traduzca,
y me dice: "Cree que te has lastimado".
Y le digo: "No, mi amor, no me he lastimado, estoy bien".
La niña estira su manita y me toca la cara.
Quizá quería mezclar el chocolate con la vainilla,
pero fuera lo que fuera,
¡fue espectacular!
Fue maravilloso.
La niña creía saber qué me pasaba,
y me dio lo que yo necesitaba:
cariño, compasión.
Y al tocarme con esa manita,
curó el dolor de un hombre grande.
¡Hurra! ¡Sí!
¡Curado!
Esa vez, no podía dejar de sonreír.
La actitud positiva es algo por lo que vale la pena luchar.
Y la lucha no es con los demás, sino que es interior.
Si queremos hacer cambios positivos en nuestra vida,
debemos ser positivos todo el tiempo.
De hecho, mi grupo sanguíneo es B positivo.
(Risas)
Ya lo sé, el tipo de la tele que dice chistes malos.
Mi hija los odia, ¡pero no me importa!
¡Hay que ser positivo!
(Ríe)
Hace unos años, un chico de 14 años que tenía vitiligo,
me pidió que mostrara mi cara en televisión.
Yo no quería.
Lo charlamos. Mi postura era que podía perder el trabajo.
Pero el chico me convenció diciendo:
"Si muestras a los demás cómo es tu cara y das una explicación,
quizá me traten a mí de otra manera".
¡Bum! Se me abrieron las anteojeras.
Me presenté en la tele,
y la respuesta fue impresionante.
No sabía qué hacer.
Aproveché la atención que recibí y la enfoqué en el chico
y en otra gente que tiene vitiligo.
Organicé un grupo de ayuda.
Al poco tiempo, se formaron grupos de ayuda como "VITFriends"
y "V-Strong" en todo el país.
En 2016 nos reunimos y celebramos el Día Mundial del Vitiligo.
El 25 de junio pasado,
se reunieron más de 300 personas
para celebrar nuestro evento nacional.
Fue increíble.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Ahora bien, no les voy a mentir
diciendo que fue rápido o fácil
encontrar un lugar positivo teniendo esta enfermedad.
Pero lo encontré.
Y también logré mucho más:
me transformé en mejor persona,
la persona que siempre quise ser.
Esa persona que puede enfrentar a un grupo de extraños en una sala
y contar algunas de las historias más duras de su vida,
y finalizar con una sonrisa,
y sentir la felicidad de ver que todos Uds. me han devuelto su sonrisa.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)